[Musica]
un giorno mi chiama Michele un mio ex
paziente un giovane ragazzo di appena 24
anni recentemente laureatosi in medicina
e specializzando in cardiologia
mi chiama sei anni di distanza dalla
conclusione di un nostro precedente
percorso terapeutico
perché qualche giorno prima ha avuto un
attacco di panico così forte da svenire
e da dover essere ricoverato in ospedale
e dove nel reparto di cardiologia
quel giorno Michele aveva litigato
furiosamente con la sua fidanzata Chiara
anche lei
studentessa in medicina è proprio lì a
un certo punto
gli si è scagliato contro con un forbice
appuntito in mano minacciando di
ucciderlo
Come mai una copia di giovani fidanzati
da sei anni
possa arrivare a tali scene di violenza
e di stress
coinvolgendoli entrambi in un percorso
di psicoterapia abbiamo scoperto che
Michele e Chiara non si conoscevano
affatto
non si sono mai conosciuti ad un livello
profondo e trasparente tale da gestire
in maniera idonea momenti di violenza
Momenti di rabbia e di stress anche
intenso
Michele e Chiara Infatti non hanno mai
dato uno all'altro l'opportunità di
conoscersi in profondità non hanno speso
il tempo opportuno per conoscersi a
fondo per sostenersi per amarsi per
potersi starsi vicino Proprio quando la
vita avrebbe chiesto loro di farlo
la loro giovane età di coppia era
scandita per la maggior parte del tempo
oltre lo studio da vari messaggi scritti
o vocali da screenshot da vari post i
loro rispettivi profili social
da varie chiamate e da ore e ore di
navigazione in internet distraendosi
quasi giornalmente rimanendo così
entrambi in una realtà Più virtuale che
fisica
Sì Michele e Chiara erano
soli pur essendo in compagnia
è proprio quando il padre dichiara È
dovuto inaspettatamente
ricoverarsi in terapia intensiva per una
grave malattia
entrambi non hanno saputo reagire in
maniera idonea a questa situazione di
dolore
di preoccupazione di stress non hanno
trovato alla loro disposizione le
risorse
necessarie per essersi vicino e per
sostenersi come invece una copia che da
6 anni
vive anche insieme Convivendo nella casa
di lei avrebbe potuto avrebbe dovuto
farlo
sto parlando di due giovani medici che
avranno nelle loro mani la salute di
tante persone man mano che svolgeranno
il loro lavoro sulle corsie
dell'ospedale
Esiste un io
Esisti tu
ed esiste un noi
che è come se ci fosse una terza persona
all'interno di una coppia
e come un'entità che ha dentro tutti gli
ingredienti che riscontriamo nei
caratteri di entrambe le persone che
formano la coppia ma anche una forma di
codice segreto che si sviluppa tra i due
che si conoscono e che si frequentano
che si amano
una forma di lealtà invisibile una
complicità
questa intesa profonda questa complicità
questa lealtà permette alla coppia di
poter affrontare con successo le sfide
della vita che tutti noi A volte
dobbiamo affrontare
ma il noi
il noi
nasce quando dedichiamo l'attenzione la
sensibilità la sincronia e il tempo
all'altro della coppia e questo quando
lo viviamo in presenza non soltanto
virtualmente pensati o ricordati
In poche parole
in internet non si trova la ricetta per
l'intesa tra due persone
in rete non riusciamo né a baciarci né
ad abbracciarci
Come mai non ci si può fare il solletico
da soli
ci sono dei studi che hanno dimostrato
che
la comunicazione umana in presenza a un
effetto pragmatico sul comportamento del
nostro prossimo cioè quello che diciamo
influenza la reazione e il comportamento
del nostro interlocutore e questo
avviene sia
attraverso il linguaggio verbale che
attraverso il linguaggio del corpo non
verbale qualche esempio
un lo sbadiglio lo è una pernacchia una
risata e silenzio uno schiaffo sono
tutte forme di comunicazione non verbale
che influenzano la persona con la quale
siamo in conversazione e anche il
seguito della conversazione
qualsiasi conversazione tra due persone
in presenza avviene a due livelli
la via Alta
e la via Bassa la via Alta tratta con
razionalità i numeri i calcoli le parole
i significati la via Bassa
si avvale della dell'informazione che
otteniamo attraverso i cinque sensi
e anche attraverso il nostro intuito
la via Bassa ci pone immediatamente in
contatto con l'altra persona e cementa
l'interazione
Anche rispetto alla via alta con tutta
la sua logica e razionalità
la nostra vita sociale costantemente
permeata da Questa interazione tra le
due vie della comunicazione umana ma in
presenza
Qui è ora
ci sono molto molti studi che dimostrano
oramai che
dobbiamo fare attenzione
a sottrarre il tempo costantemente
giornalmente alla Vita in presenza con i
nostri prossimi con i nostri simili
stando a lungo in modo prolungato con in
contatto con gli strumenti tecnologici
Ci sono numerosi studi scientifici che
danno le informazioni rispetto
a un deterioramento della nostra memoria
sia a lungo che a breve termine anche
una crescente incapacità di mantenere
l'attenzione di conservarla anche solo
per pochi minuti
e questo soprattutto si riscontra nei
giovani
i giovani sono coloro che spendono più
tempo sono più curiosi e più entusiasti
Ma dobbiamo auspicarci tutti
una costante attenzione un contatto
costante monitoraggio di come Questi
strumenti digitali sempre più moderni
sempre più avanzati vengono utilizzati
in questa fascia di età
ci siamo sempre domandati Come mai possa
il cervello plasmare la cultura vi
nomino qui Norman Deutsch
brillante Studioso e psichiatra canadese
che nel suo libro The Brain that chainst
Itself il cervello che cambiò se stesso
disse questa interessante parole
il cervello plasma la cultura ma anche
la cultura plasma il cervello
dimostrando attraverso una ricchissima
documentazione scientifica come le
nostre abitudini della vita quotidiana
le nostre consuetudini abbinate ad un
uso costante
entusiasmante devi sempre più nuovi
strumenti tecnologici plasmi il
funzionamento della nostra mente e anche
la percezione della nostra realtà
circostante
mentre è ovvio che il cervello plasma la
cultura e per questo basta solo pensare
all'evoluzione dell'uomo dall'uomo
Sapiens a oggi
e meno evidente che la cultura plasma il
nostro cervello
Eppure basta pensarci come le nostre
abitudini le nostre convinzioni i
modelli comportamentali premiati dalla
società possano
plasmare il funzionamento della nostra
mente del nostro cervello delle nostre
idee
dobbiamo fare attenzione
per noi stessi e per le generazioni
future In modo tale di essere pronti ad
abbracciare la novità e nel mentre
adattiamo la nostra vita alla sempre
maggiore evoluzione di questi strumenti
dobbiamo avere al cuore l'equilibrio tra
la logica e l'emotività
l'equilibrio tra il tempo che dedichiamo
al mondo virtuale e al mondo fisico
Ma perché dobbiamo preoccuparci di
mantenere sempre questa questo
equilibrio nella nostra interazione
umana
stiamo ragionando in base a una
preoccupazione
pessimistica oppure
stiamo ragionando solo perché non
conosciamo il fenomeno in piena
evoluzione Ed è pieno cambiamento
e la risposta si basa sui dati che
abbiamo oggi a disposizione
e purtroppo la risposta è rischio di
demenza
demenza digitale
È un termine che c'è stato esportato
dalla Corea del Sud
Dove è stato utilizzato per la prima
volta
e il paese nel quale gli strumenti
digitali e
le nuove tecnologie sono
moderne avanzate sofisticate vengono
utilizzate ovunque perfino nella scuola
materna
Sì ci sono dei studi come per esempio il
gruppo di ricercatori della Stanford
University
capitanati dal professore
Rudy P
come anche il sudditi I ricercatori
della oxfort University Jerome spazio
Loro
dimostrano come un uso costante
permanente quotidiano a lungo nel giorno
nelle giornate nostre dei nuovi e sempre
più sofisticati strumenti tecnologici
possono incidere negativamente sul
nostro equilibrio psico emotivo possono
a volte portare i nostri giovani a
isolarsi
e forse anche a sviluppare delle forme
di
disturbi dell'umore
il nostro cervello è socievole
il nostro cervello necessita di essere
nutrito
quasi costantemente
dal
relazionarsi con il nostro prossimo in
presenza
il nostro cervello ha bisogno di quella
danza quella forma di tango
che si sviluppa ogni qualvolta entriamo
in una relazione empatica con il nostro
prossimo
il nostro cervello essere socievole
sviluppa le sue capacità maggiormente
diventiamo quasi si potrebbe dire più
intelligente non che empatici
Più sani
abbiamo dei motivi ragionevoli
per conservare il buon funzionamento del
nostro cervello
per garantire al nostro cervello un
funzionamento sano a lungo nel tempo e
lo possiamo fare coltivando la
consapevolezza
e le sane abitudini
sapete
io ho bevuto l'acqua del Tevere
era limpida potabile e buona
Per fare ciò
sono salita sul monte Fumaiolo
alla roccia dalla quale sorge il fiume
sacro che giace ai piedi di Roma
e quindi
penso intimamente
che
in questo tempo della nostra storia
è giunto il momento di tornare al nostro
centro
di tornare
alla nostra Fonte al nostro bambino
interiore se vogliamo chiamarlo così
al nostro primo genuino se
dobbiamo conoscere a fondo e intimamente
il funzionamento della nostra mente le
sue capacità ancora inesplorate a fondo
dobbiamo entrare in contatto con questa
essenza di noi stessi
per comprendere
come funziona
e per scoprire le sue risorse nascoste
dobbiamo fare in modo che conosciamo
intimamente la nostra mente prima ancora
di avventurarci con curiosità e ed
entusiasmo nella nostra seconda
o terza dimensione umana aumentandola
oltre necessità
viviamo un'epoca di grandi cambiamenti
di grandi sfide
di grandi scoperte scientifiche
e nel Mentre
aspettiamo il cambiamento alla fine
cambiamo noi stessi
ci riuscirà a tutti ad abbracciare il
cambiamento e tutte le scoperte
meravigliose della tecnologia di oggi
riusciremo ad abbracciare il cambiamento
se veramente dedicassimo con disciplina
e con buon senso la tensione
anche al profondo e intimo di noi stessi
e del funzionamento della nostra mente
il Buddha disse
Il cambiamento non è mai doloroso
Ma la resistenza al cambiamento lo è
e quindi Vale ancora di più
di essere Attenti a noi a come ci
funziona il cervello perché non abbiamo
molto
se non le menti della prossima
generazione per assicurarci una società
di prosperità e di pace
e se veramente dedicassimo al tempo e la
disciplina opportuna per conoscerci Nel
profondo di noi stessi e per
utilizzare positivamente le risorse
nascoste della nostra mente allora non
ci sarà più bisogno di opporre
resistenza nessun cambiamento
buon metà verso a tutti
[Applauso]